wenn ich nur sieben Sachen auf einer
einsame Insel mitnehmen dürfte dann
werden es die Zutaten für den leckersten
San Sebastian Cheesecake das ist das
einfachste Rezept dass es gibt aber
dennoch gibt es ganz viele Probleme bei
der Zubereitung denn wichtig ist dass
ihr die Originalzutaten verwendet
tauscht Philadelphia nicht gegen billig
Frischkäse aus nimmt das beste
Vanilleextrakt dass ihr bekommt frische
Zitrone und bitte kein Zitronenaroma und
verwendet alle Zutaten auf
Zimmertemperatur macht zwischendurch die
Küche sauber sonst stresst ihr euch im
Nachgang und füllt den Teig in eine
Springform die relativ auslaufsicher ist
uns ärgert ihr euch denkt dran Leute
jeder Backofen backt anders und bei
jedem braucht der Kuchen vielleicht eine
Minute länger oder eine Minute kürzer
das ist einfach der leckerste Cheesecake
der Welt er darf oben nicht zu braun
werden und darf nur leicht
karamellisieren und in der Mitte muss er
schmecken wie lecker ist aber
Vanillepudding